Well, Friday night,
we all got hit by the terrible news that Ruth Bader Ginsburg has passed away at
the age of 87 or fifth bout of cancer.
And I was talking to someone and they said,
I think at least what I felt it's like,
you kind of felt like she was going to hang on until, uh,
after this election.
And it was clear that she was fighting to hang on and she's a very strong
person, but, um, her strength ran out, uh, you know,
we're all human and she passed away Friday night.
Uh, and the question is, uh, what does this mean? I mean,
the first thing is you, you honor the passing of an icon,
someone who is a trailblazer, uh, uh,
for really, um, women certainly in the legal field,
but she, I think she was bigger than, than that, where she stood up for,
uh, an evolving sense of what human rights were, uh,
over her career, really transcended generations. Uh, you know what I mean,
what a full life, uh, I think someone said, it's like, you know,
you can't imagine living a more impactful, more important life, uh,
leading a more important career than she did. So on one hand,
you just look up and say, wow,
like so grateful that she was among us and did what she has
done. Um,
and that lasted unfortunately for apparently about, uh,
30 seconds before then people started turning towards what this means in terms
of the Supreme court, uh, this election,
whether Trump is going to nominate someone,
which I think he announced he is going to,
and then whether the Senate would move forward to confirm a new justice,
despite the fact that the election is at this point
44 days away. Uh,
and the average Supreme court confirmation process takes 2.2 months
and that's an, a normal circumstance. So, uh,
so to me, it's really
awful that after sandbagging Merrick, Garland, uh,
in 2016, where they say, Hey, look,
it's only a year until the election. Like,
let's not deal with this until after the election. Uh,
and then now when you're in the reverse situation, but instead of having a year,
you have six weeks and you're like, no, no, this time we're gonna,
we're just going to cram this through because it's a, you know,
a different situation. Um, like that strikes, I think,
any reasonable person as utterly ridiculous and awful and,
like, you know, it's, it's just a clear, uh,
double standard where you take one approach.
If it's a justice that represents a viewpoint, you don't like, and then, uh,
when the shoe's on the other foot, then,
then you take a totally different approach.
So here's a couple of dots. Um, one like it's heartbreaking.
Like she was a, um, even president Trump was asked, like if we got to,
they got a very real candid reaction of him.
Cause he found out the news Friday night from a reporter after his rally, um,
which quick comment his team should have told him between the walk from the
rally to his press. That's what we would do and be like, Hey, by the way,
if so-and-so died or this broke, that news, whatever it is, anyway, he did say,
wow, like I have nothing to say, except she's an amazing woman.
Like she lived an amazing life. Um, this is very sad, something like that. Um,
and then it is heartbreaking. The reality is though,
what you just said is that this is going to be extremely politicized and we're
not even gonna wait. It's just gonna, it's already started. Um,
so I thought it'd be,
we wanted to hop on the pod and break this down. Um,
because this is your September surprise.
This will be the focal point of election and Tim Alberta.
Who's one of our buddies from the campaign. Um,
just wrote a piece in Politico talking about what Trump and McConnell would or
could do, but one of the things that's fascinating, Andrew,
and this is why it matters is that the Supreme court
is, and I quote the most and quote,
the most important factor in voting for president or when they go to vote
for 21% of the electorate, 21% of all voters,
this is the Mo this is the thing they care about. Um,
so thoughts on how this affects Republicans affects Democrats,
like it's gonna effect, this is the most important thing for almost everybody,
um, when it comes to voting and you now have this hanging in the balance before,
one of the more important elections we've ever had.
Well,
one legitimate reason to be concerned about having an even number of justices
right now. And this is before, uh, you know,
we get to what you just described is that back in 2000,
the Supreme court essentially helped decide the election between, uh,
Al Gore and, and, and George W. Bush, uh,
you know, they decided five,
four along unfortunately party lines about what to do with the Florida recount.
Uh, and, and so you have a very real impact on potentially the resolution on the
election, uh, which to me is another reason why it's,
it's terrible for, uh, us to try and cram a new justice in,
and then have that just as literally, maybe turn around and decide an election,
uh, days later. I mean, like, I don't think that strikes anyone as a good idea.
Um, but to your point,
there are millions of Americans who have been focused on
the Supreme court and other courts around the country and Republicans have done
a superior job of motivating their base around, uh,
judicial appointments. Uh, they, they, they're very,
very consistent on that and they,
they care more about non Supreme court, judicial appointments,
I believe, uh, then the other side, uh,
and they're smart because those judges ended up deciding a
lot of things, uh, that never even get to the Supreme court. I mean,
it's not like the Supreme court hears everything, you know,
that you have to go through several levels, uh, to, to get there.
How Trump won over the evangelical, right, is that, Hey,
you don't have to love Trump,
but he's going to stand for conservative values on, in, on our Supreme court,
here's a list of justices.
I'm going to nominate you drop that in may of 2016 before the election.
So that sorry to interrupt with that a big.
No, not at all. You're right. They're very smart and deliberate about.
It. They knew it. They knew the numbers.
And evangelical voters listen, and they say, look,
I can hold my nose and vote for this man, because he's going to stand up for,
uh, the things I care about instead, or whatever that, whatever they believe in.
Well, I mean, that's, that's,
I think the most common issue for folks who are focused on, uh,
these appointments is, uh,
is pro-life versus pro-choice the big one now.
So the question now,
if you look at the actual ins and outs of nominating and
confirming a Supreme court justice,
you need several Republican senators to say, look, I'm not going to do this. Uh,
given the timeline, given the circumstances, um,
you need approximately three to come out and say that that,
that they're not down for this hurry up confirmation process.
Uh,
and there there's a real possibility that those three Republican senators exist.
So if you, and I believe, uh,
at least a couple of them have already signaled that they are not going to go
along with a confirmation process.
And some of them are up for reelection right now in a really tough races. Uh,
Susan Collins in Maine, um, is one of them.
So hope is not lost in the sense that, uh,
there's a real chance that enough senators look up and say,
look, it's, it's really, really, uh,
not appropriate for us to cram a Supreme court justice,
uh, in this timeframe six weeks before an election, uh, you know,
after we essentially waited a year, uh,
in 2016 saying that the people should decide.
I think if we have a consistent message right now,
it should be let the people decide, but, you know,
and to your point about how this is going to affect the election,
it's going to energize voters on both sides. Uh,
there are many people who are going to look up and say, wow,
we need to get Trump reelected because he can appoint a replacement to Ruth
Bader Ginsburg.
And there are many voters around the country who say we really need to get Joe
and Commonwealth liked it because they're going to appoint a replacement to Ruth
Bader Ginsburg. And that to me is appropriate. Like that is a much,
much better process for us to determine who replaces RBG
than doing this, uh, completely rushed and
inconsistent with past practice, uh, confirmation process that some people are,
are looking to, um, to, to shepherd through in record time. I mean,
the whole thing just leave a terrible, terrible sense, uh, in many,
many American's minds as to what this process
became.
And especially if it turns out that this new justice ends up having an impact
on, uh, the outcome of the election,
because there is a real chance that there are legal challenges associated with
this election.
I think this probably is a net positive for Republican turnout,
more than Democrat turnout in the sense that I feel like Democrats have a
million reasons to want to vote against the Donald or fill their
principles violated in certain ways. But Republicans may have been on the fence,
but I don't love this Trump guy. And he's like,
I'm just gonna stay home or now like, well, I now know I'm getting my vote.
If we win guarantees a conservative justice on the, on the court, um,
that is more powerful. Um, now let me ask you this. Um,
or could it be more powerful? Let me ask you this though. Um,
this is what's Tim Alberta's point. We're just fascinated. He's like, if,
so on one hand, Trump could say, Hey,
I want to nominate a Supreme court justice before the election. Here it is.
I'm going to get done. Um, cause who knows,
or they could wait, they could say like, we're elected me and I will do this.
Um, and even if he loses,
they still might be able to pass this thing and approve it between the end of
November 3rd or whenever they actually, we count the votes.
And when Mike Pence swears in, uh, the next,
you know, the next Senate, right, the next Congress,
I think that's the Vice-President's job. Do you? And that's his point?
He's like Mitch McConnell has options here and he might actually choose to wait,
um, cause he can still get what he wants,
but it affects the election in a different way.
What are your thoughts on how to play that? Or if they,
which way they lean either? I don't know. It's interesting question.
Well, the excitement for Republicans, um,
could be elevated either way. Like if you don't,
if you don't get the justice, say, look,
you gotta vote for Trump so we can get this justice. That's very,
very powerful motivation. Um,
if they get the justice through, I would argue that,
you know, you would also motivate the same group of voters, um,
because they would see that that voting for Trump gets
results in a particular way. Yeah. So, uh,
but I agree that there, there is a tactical issue. Uh, you know, it,
it could be exciting to Republican voters who are motivated around this, uh,
to say, uh, you gotta get out there if you want this justice. Um,
I would also suggest though that, to me,
let's say Trump loses and that outcome is determined in November.
And then for the Senate then to turn around and say, Hey,
the American people chose Joe, but now we're,
we're still going to go ahead and cram in this appointment. Um,
I think that they would have a very,
very hard time convincing both the American people and uh,
even the Republican senators that,
that was appropriate in the least,
I think there would be a half a dozen Republican senators, uh,
who would stand up and say, look, uh, you know, we just lost an election. Uh,
you know, like we're literally in a lame duck session in the last month,
the waning days of, of this Senate,
like some of us are leaving, like, uh, like I don't think, um,
I don't think that process, uh, would, would, uh, stand up personally.
I mean, like I've been wrong before about cause you know, people,
people aren't very principled in some of these situations,
but I think that would be in some ways the most distasteful
approach.
So here's what I say. I want to know if you agree with this,
like this is all we can kind of say right now because you never know how these
things play out. Um, but here's what I'd say to look out for.
I don't want what your thoughts, why you think I'm right.
I say one lookout for the Republicans to use this,
I will say extremely well to help Trump win in 2020. Um,
cause I think Mitch McConnell while he's a scumbag and the definition of a
hypocrite, he's a genius. He is a political genius. If you will, like,
he's a mastermind at winning elections, you should not win.
And getting these pastors should not be passed and doing things the American
people do not like, or even, um,
have any sort of tendency to approve on a majority basis.
But I'd say political side from the Republicans is going to use well,
I think I'd be interested to see how this engages the, um,
the women's vote in 2020. That's the second piece of this. Um,
because I do think that's what RBG stood for and that,
that puts this issue front and center on the ballot to me. Um, and then third,
I'm really interested in how the Democrats can respond to this
without, um, frankly you're looking kind of lame or soft where it's like, no,
don't do it wait for us. Or I, you know,
like without looking reactive or passive in a certain way. Um,
but those are my three, I dunno, anything to watch out for what you think.
Yeah. The, the the message should be let the people decide. Um,
we have an election coming up in, in, in six weeks. Uh,
one reaction I did see, uh,
that people were taking right now is to donate to Mitch McConnell's opponent,
Amy McGrath. Uh, and,
and I would suggest that there are a couple of better things you could do than
that though. That's a very natural, emotional reaction. Um, but, uh,
Amy McGrath not hurting for money. Um.
Money is not helping when right now she's not going to lose enough money. Yes.
Extra dollars in Aquafina, make note nine.
Senate races open that are closer right now that could use the money. Sorry.
Yeah, exactly. That's exactly right. Like,
like if you're thinking I'm going to donate, um, to Mitch McConnell's opponent,
pick one of the other races, uh, and donate to them instead, uh,
like Lindsey Graham's opponent,
Jamie Harrison's actually neck and neck with him in South Carolina,
that's a political earthquake in the making. So you don't, you can donate that.
Like there are a bunch of other races that make more sense. Uh, and the,
the second thing is to try and put pressure on
some of these moderate Republicans are going to be, uh,
trying to decide whether or not to go along with this, uh,
hurry up confirmation process. So Mitt Romney's one, uh,
Lisa Murkowski is another Susan Collins is another, uh,
and there are a couple of others, um, that I believe are sway a bowl.
Um, and that could be for political purposes, if they're up for reelection, um,
or it could be, uh, no, uh,
just an emotional appeal as like your, their constituents constituent.
Let's say you're their constituent and you voted for them and didn't vote for
them. Say, look, you know, you're like, you're my Senator, uh, that, like,
I feel strongly that you should just let the people decide.
Let's let the election go. Like, uh, you know,
working on the winnable Senate races and then working on the moderate
Republicans who are going to decide this thing, um, or their opponents,
if that's the way you decide to go, you know, like, um, then, uh,
that to me would be like a couple of very concrete things that
you could do. Uh, another thing would, would be just to,
to do more of whatever you're doing now. So, uh, phone bank,
call people, text, bank volunteer, make sure and vote,
get your friends to register, to vote, particularly in swing States, um,
around the country. Um, so those are some of the things that,
that I think we should be doing. The Senate looks very, very, uh,
winnable for Dems this cycle,
where they could get a slight majority if they win some of these races.
So the Senate races that are close and closer to
McGraths are in Maine, North Carolina, South Carolina, Georgia, Arizona,
Michigan, Colorado, Texas, even Alaska. So those are the number of States. Um,
give me more info, yank speaks listeners. Um, so I agree. Um,
we learned this a lot when we were running,
is that if you actually call your Congressman or Senator,
they don't get a lot of calls like this. So, um,
if you're in many States and got five friends to call,
that actually has a way bigger impact than you think. Um,
because people are like, Oh, you don't listen to people.
The people don't actually talk to them very often. Um, so that actually works.
Let me ask you this.
And I think it's a good way to close is this feels dark to me.
This is a sad day. This is a sad moment. Um,
I, I think ignoring your political ideology,
I think a balanced court is better than an overweight Republican one,
particularly when I think that the,
like the popular vote voted for Clinton last time.
Like I think the majority of the country is leaning more left at least in terms
of sheer numbers. Um, so this feels dark and heavy.
Um, and I there's a lot of people out there. Um,
we're looking for a sign of hope. Um,
what to you, what's the positive spin on this?
What do you gives you hope as we come down the pipe, um, post RBGs legacy.
First day, it really is reflecting on what a tremendous, uh,
figure and leader.
She was just feeling like a sense of history. I mean, uh,
Evelyn was incredibly sad to hear of her passing, just, uh,
Americans around the country, uh, are,
are devastated and just reflecting on what she's she means to so
many of us, I was actually thinking to myself, wow. Her passing. Um,
I was trying to think of other people that would have had a similar impact on,
on millions of people around the country. And it's a very, very short list.
I mean, she she's really, uh, one of the, uh,
sort of the Mount Rushmore of, uh, of, uh, living American figures and, and,
you know, until this week, um, uh, the,
and one of the,
so I think there are a few reasons why we're sad right now there are,
and they're all important.
Number one is a human being that we are all that we all admired and
treasured is, has gone. Uh,
number two is the tough truth that while Trump has
nominated and confirmed two Supreme court justices,
they were replacing conservative justices. Uh, so we, we still,
as you were saying, Zach have like a moderately balanced court. I mean,
unfortunately a lot of rulings are going five, four along party lines, um,
with Roberts as sort of the swing, but you still have this sense of balance.
RBG is a very progressive vote.
And if you replaced the progressive vote with a very, uh,
conservative justice and some of the folks that they have on the short list, uh,
to be the next Supreme court justice are very conservative.
Uh, then that's, uh, a major,
major shift for the court where you have then six, three or five,
four conservative majority is consistently down the board, um,
which is why we're all hurting, uh, on the side.
And then the third thing is this for bidding sense that, uh,
the Senate may abandoned principle. And, uh, and,
and because of the abandonment of principle,
there's a sense that our institutions are, uh, eroding even further.
Uh,
and in many ways I feel like this election is about the integrity of American
institutions and our trust in them.
And that that trust has been slipping for years and decades for a variety of
reasons. Uh, and now the Supreme court,
which many of us have already questioned, um,
whether it's truly an apolitical entity over the last number of months and
years, but like now is in danger of becoming, uh, you know,
even more, um,
of a political football. It feels like, you know what I mean? Like, and,
and so like, I mean,
heck I remember reading Supreme court rulings and like spending hours,
like pouring over the reasoning and, and whatnot.
And then now it seems like that stuff's not actually how these things go down.
It's just like, well, you know, like we were there, we pointed this person.
Like, I felt like, I felt like people were like, they had their party line,
you know, they were going,
and then someone wrote some sort of dissertation or response wherever it's
called to explain it to them.
Yeah. Like backing into it. Uh, you know,
and each Supreme court justice has four brilliant clerks,
uh, who are like some of the best law school grads in the country. That frankly,
you, you could get like a pretty good explanation for it.
I get it right. Bait. You debated, you know, you take the other side. Yeah,
for sure. And there are logical reasons for a whole bunch. I mean,
like whether you agree with them or not,
you can find facts to support your opinion all the time. Um, sorry, keep going.
I mean, I mean, it's like a sinking feeling, the sinking feeling you have,
because, you know, like you'd like to believe that legal reasoning transcends,
uh, like political beliefs. Um, so,
so these are the reasons why we're all sad Zack and like they're all very
legitimate, important reasons. Uh, like the, the,
the thing I would say that, um, you can take away from this, um,
that you could frame as a positive is that this will make it
indisputably,
crystal clear to everyone on both sides on any side,
how important this election is. Like all of a sudden, you know,
you look up and say, wait a minute, uh,
there are a lot of fundamental, uh,
legal rights that you may take for granted.
Now that may actually be changed or called into question, uh,
in the days to come. Uh, and so if,
uh, if there were folks who were,
who were on the fence about getting out there and voting, um,
on either side and there is this instinct that you,
you suggested before that Tim suggests that it's like that this is going to
energize one side more than the other. Um, but T to me,
the positive from this is to just show how important this election is going to
be, and that we all need to do everything we can, uh,
to get people out, to vote, to, uh,
to fight for the candidates that we believe in. Um,
because there's a lot at stake,
like a lot of things that we have grown to just believe
as true about American life, um,
may be called into question. Uh,
if this election goes in particular direction.
I think what gives me hope is, um, this, yes,
it puts importance on the election and your best case scenario right now to me
is we,
we turn out as a country cooler heads prevail in November,
and it's such a stomping that
your congressmen, your senators are on the way out.
There's the be ideally embarrassed from a clean sweep and that there's no way in
their right mind without massive revolt, um,
that they would try to push us across the finish line after the American people
speak on November 3rd. That to me is, is a realistic outcome in our best case,
I think.
No, I think there's a chance you see record turnout, um, in part,
because I think there are some folks who are going to be voting at higher levels
because of mail-in voting actually.
And people are, you know, they're getting, I mean, I love like people to me,
the NBA, every single NBA player right now is wearing like vote and running ads.
Like to me, that's that that's never happened for my lifetime.
I don't think it has a zero impact. Um, and if it gets 5,000, 10,000, 50,000,
a hundred thousand people in some of these States to vote and get a whole new
election, and I will say,
FYI people falling in the democratic primary this year,
2020 record turnout record turnouts for Biden,
for Biden, um, the same primaries we were in, you know,
Iowa New Hampshire record turnout. So that gives me hope, you know,
um.
Let's, let's, yeah, let's get out there and fight for it and vote. I mean,
that's really the big message you can take from this, uh, and,
and continue to be inspired by Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
because you can imagine the arc of her life and her career and the impact she's
had been, you know, uh, if any of us can accomplish anything,
even like, you know, five, 10% of that. I mean, like, you know,
we we'd consider ourselves very, very, very fortunate.
Successful. Yeah.
So thank you guys for tuning in this is our first kind of rapid response,
but this is the fitting one, right? No better reason than,
than the passing of a, of a goat, the goat. Um.
Yeah. It's passing out in historic figure. Uh, let's make her proud. You know,
the thing I'd say is like, for people who are sad right now,
just take that sadness and translate it into action,
because that's what she would want for us.